PENG YING: Hi, my name
is Peng Ying.
And I'm a developer programs
engineer on Google Commerce.
And speaking with me today are
Mihai Ionescu, a developer
advocate with a storied history
on Google Chrome and
our product manager for Google
Checkout, Satyajeet Salgar.
I'm really excited and nervous
about today, mostly nervous.
This marks our first-ever
commerce track at Google I/O.
And we hope to kick it
off with a bang.
We have a lot of great
information to share with you.
And if you want to rate
us, you can use the
speaker meter link.
And if you want to shout us out
on Twitter, use #commerce.
So today we'll be covering a
little bit of everything.
First, we'll cover what Checkout
is and the benefits
that it provides to developers
like yourself.
Then since Checkout is an
e-commerce enabler for many
Google products and APIs, we'll
show you the various
ways of implementing Checkout.
Then we'll dive into how
Checkout works and
the APIs behind it.
Once you've established a
foundation of knowledge, we'll
show you how these tools
and APIs are
used in the real world.
Finally we'll finish with the
challenges that Checkout has
faced and provide a preview
of commerce at Google.
So let's get started with
a brief overview of what
Checkout is.
Checkout is an alternative
purchase flow.
And what that means is that
instead of just sending the
payment credentials and the
amounts to your payment
processor instead you'll need
to define the items a
customer's purchasing, any
discounts, and your tax and
shipping settings.
And send that to Google
Checkout.
And what this allows Checkout
to do is control the entire
purchase flow from a customer
creating an account or signing
in to them choosing the shipping
methods, adding new
payment methods and specifying
where they want to ship it to,
then confirming the order and
viewing the receipt page.
Since the merchant defines all
of the customer information as
well or all of the order
information, a customer can
easily log in to Google Checkout
and view their order
history from multiple stores.
And just so you know, The Ping
Pong Super Store is in no way
related to myself.
The merchant can also log in
and see a history of sales.
And since the orders take place
on Google Checkout, they
can use the Google Checkout
merchant center to process
these orders.
Or they can use the notification
and order
processing APIs to process
them from their server.
So put your hand up if you've
purchased something from the
web in the past two weeks?
It could be an app.
It could be something retail.
It looks like a lot of you.
And then how many of you
are selling online?
Sold something from the web
in the past two weeks?
Wow, you guys are all attending
the right session.
You've all probably encountered
a few really
annoying parts of purchasing
and selling online.
Well, other than paying your
credit card bills.
And this is just a short
anecdote from my personal
experiences.
So a majority of my
team is here.
And then some of us are going to
go to Yosemite this weekend
to go hiking.
I think we're going to go
try to hike Half Dome.
My friends told me it's pretty
scenic, so I wanted to buy a
pretty nice camera to bring
with me and take
some awesome photos.
I found this one
at Ritz Camera.
And it had the best price I
could find online, so I
purchased it there.
I also wanted a pair
of hiking shoes.
Last time I was at Yosemite,
I slipped and fell once.
And it was kind of
embarrassing.
I found this pair at a mom and
pop shop that I didn't really
know, but I still bought
them anyway.
And lastly, I wanted to buy a
camera bag because I didn't
want this camera just swinging
around my neck while I hiked.
I was in the store the other
day, and I found one that I
liked, but it was a little bit
expensive in the store.
So I pulled out my cell phone
and I purchased it--
well, I did comparison shopping
first. And then I
purchased it through my cell
phone in the store.
And here are some of
the pain points.
For most separate sites, you
needed to fill in the same
information over and over
again, creating numerous
separate accounts at
multiple merchants.
I don't know about you, but
sometimes I have to try two to
three different login password
combinations before I'm
actually logged in at sites
I don't often use.
And if I don't recognize the
store, it's very difficult for
me to provide my payment
credentials even if they have
the best price by far.
Lastly, the mobile purchases
is a market that's growing
very quickly.
And not all stores have a
mobile-specific purchase flow.
And if you've tried purchasing
something from your cell
phone, you probably know that
it's not a great experience.
Entering your credentials on a
virtual keyboard is not the
most pleasant of experiences.
So Google Checkout can help
solve these problems.
For buyers, take a look at
what Google has done
internally.
Almost all of Google's products
use Checkout to monetize.
And a single account can be
used across all of them.
Not only can one account be used
to purchase from Google,
but it can be used to purchase
from external sites, such as
B&H Photo, Buy.com, eBags,
and thousands more.
Like Open ID and OAuth, a
single account to enable
transactions from across the
web is a powerful tool.
This account also enables you to
purchase with a few clicks
across multiple platforms from
all merchants that have
implemented Checkout.
Purchasing from a Xoom, Nexus S,
Google TV is now simple and
easy with only a few clicks.
Lastly, Checkout serves as an
intermediary to the merchant
so that they never receive
your payment credentials.
This means that should they be
hacked, you don't have to go
out and get a new credit card.
For developers and merchants,
implementing the API enables
tens of millions of buyers to
purchase from your site with a
few simple clicks.
And regardless of the device
that your buyer may be using,
the Checkout flow automatically
scales and
handles device limitations.
Instead of having to spend time
coding out buy flows and
multiple device formats,
Checkout allows you to focus
on your core products.
We also have the payment
guarantee, which ensures
payments for orders covered.
And 98% of all Checkout
orders are covered by
this payment guarantee.
There's also a powerful risk
engine that analyzes each
order and, should it be deemed
fraudulent, automatically
cancels it.
An added benefit of having
Checkout serving as the
intermediary is that we handle
PCI compliance for you.
How many of you know what
PCI compliance is?
Please put up your hands.
That's a lot of you.
That's more than I expected.
But for those of you who don't,
you don't even need to
know what PCI compliance is.
Since you never receive the
customer's credit card
information to receive payments,
you don't need to be
certified for PCI compliance.
And just in case you're curious,
it's certification
that ensures your security
systems are up to the
standards set by the
Payment Card
Industry Standard Council.
And it can be expensive and
time-consuming to acquire.
Lastly, we want to ensure that
each API is simple to use and
easy to implement.
We provide tools and client
libraries to make
integration a breeze.
But that's not the limit of
Checkout's functionality.
Checkout is an e-commerce
enabler.
It allows for purchases across
a variety of products.
Did you know that if you've
ever purchased an Android
application, a Chrome Web Store
application, an Apps
Marketplace app, or even
purchased storage for Picasa
that you already have a Google
Checkout account?
And this is just a small sample
list of Google products
that use Checkout to monetize.
E-commerce in general is growing
by leaps and bounds.
And it seems like new
e-commerce sites are
opening every day.
Group buys, sample sales, app
stores, music, video,
vacation, services, more
and more things
are being sold online.
And more importantly, more and
more people are purchasing
these things.
Leveraging our own products,
we've seen tremendous growth
in Checkout.
So tremendous that I don't even
have PR-approved hard
numbers I can share with you.
So I have to use the abstract
unit of measure of a rainbow.
And I can only say that the
number of transactions has not
only increased to a double
rainbow, but it's increased to
a triple rainbow.
What does it mean?
It means that the number of
transactions has grown
three-fold in the six
months between June
and December of '10.
And the graph, while a little
bit artsy, is an accurate
representation of the daily
transaction volume of Checkout.
So now that you're hopefully
interested in implementing
Checkout, Mihai is going
to show you the
various ways to integrate.
MIHAI IONESCUE: Thank
you, Peng.
How are you guys doing?
All right.
Welcome to the first-ever
Commerce Track at Google I/O.
So you are excited about
e-commerce, right?
OK.
You're at the right session.
And I know e-commerce is
fun especially when
you're making money.
Now Peng gave you a good
overview of what Google
Checkout is all about.
Now let's see how we can put
all that together and build
e-commerce solutions.
There are quite a few ways to
integrate Google Checkout from
very simple implementations all
the way to advanced ones.
The simple implementations
abstract the way the
complexities of the Checkout
API, while the advanced ones
take full advantage of it.
For the rest of the talk, we'll
go over these popular
integrations, have some fun with
sample code, then learn
more about the Checkout API, and
finally see how everything
comes together in a real case
e-commerce implementation.
Let's start with the Buy Now
button, the simplest way to
implement Google Checkout.
The Buy Now button was
specifically designed to sell
a single item in one
transaction.
Only minimal programming
skills are required.
You just copy and paste a
pre-generated HTML code snippet.
Next we have the Store Gadget.
With a Store Gadget, you get
to sell multiple items per
transaction, and you also get a
simple inventory management
through Google Docs
spreadsheet.
Adding a Store Gadget
is as simple as
adding a Buy Now button.
Copy and paste a code snippet.
You get all that through an
online wizard, which generates
the online store and the
inventory spreadsheet.
Now the Store Gadget and the Buy
Now button are simple and
easy to use.
But what if you want more
features or more options?
Let's say you want more control
over your website's
look and feel, or you want to
use your own order processing
system instead of the Google
Merchant Center.
For that, you need a Shopping
Cart solution.
Implementations vary from very
basic, where you have a
pre-integrated shopping cart, to
very complex, custom-built
carts where you have full
control over every aspect of
the implementation.
You decide which solution is
right for you based on your
e-commerce site.
You can implement
a cart yourself.
You can use a shopping
cart from Google.
Or you can use a shopping
cart from one of
our integration partners.
If you want to learn more about
advanced e-commerce
solutions or custom-built carts,
we actually have quite
a few partners here
at Google I/O.
And I encourage you to
go talk to them.
They're in the Developer's
Sandbox area right here on
this floor.
Now to show you how simple it
is to add a shopping cart to
your site, we added one right
here on this page.
This is not a screen shot.
It's a real shopping cart
provided by Google.
I can add items to the cart.
I can change my mind and
update the cart.
And then I can buy all this
stuff with one click.
Now, how easy was it to add
that shopping cart?
It was just a simple
two-step process.
First, include a Google
Shopping Cart script,
basically one line of code.
Next, annotate your products
with various attributes.
Just a few more lines of code.
The annotations are used by the
Shopping Cart script to
identify the items for sale and
update the shopping cart.
And that's all it takes to
add a simple shopping
cart to your site.
Now, how about customizing
the shopping cart?
Making it fit nicely
with your web site?
Well, you can also do that.
The Google Shopping Cart is
built with JavaScript and CSS.
And thus, it's very
customizable.
For example, you can control
the cart location.
Place it anywhere on
the page not just
the default top corner.
You can also change the
appearance of the cart.
Use your own images,
colors, borders,
backgrounds, and so forth.
And finally, you have full
control over the entire
behavior of the cart.
As I mentioned, the cart is
built with JavaScript.
And it offers you JavaScript
functions
which you can control.
For example, you can query or
change the items in the cart.
Or you can use JavaScript
callbacks to handle all kinds
of cart events.
Now this is very powerful.
And later in the talk, we'll
see how we can you use they
JavaScript Shopping Cart
functions together with the
Checkout API to build a real
e-commerce solution.
But before that, let's have a
quick recap of the integration
solutions we've seen so far.
From easier to advanced, the Buy
Now button is the simplest
to implement.
Specifically designed to sell a
single item per transaction.
The Store Gadget allows you
to sell multiple items per
transaction while maintaining
the simplicity and ease of the
implementation.
And finally, shopping carts
come in a variety of
implementations from very basic,
as we just saw, where
you can add a shopping cart with
simple HTML and CSS to
very complex, custom-built carts
with powerful features.
With that said, now it's a good
time to take a deep dive
into the Checkout API.
Peng will take over again
and give you a
Checkout API crash course.
PENG YING: Thanks Mihai.
It's pretty simple and
powerful, right?
Now let's understand how these
tools work and to continue
building out your foundation
of knowledge of
the Checkout API.
So Checkout is comprised
of several APIs.
There are APIs that
enable purchases.
The Cart API, which allows you
to define the items being
purchased and your tax and
shipping settings.
The Merchant Calculations API,
which allows you to define a
URL that will call back to join
your customer's buy flow
that allows you to custom
calculate discounts, taxes,
shipping, and shipping values.
We have APIs for fulfillment.
The Notification API, where
Checkout will send your server
notifications for syncing
and order processing.
There's a Notification History
API that allows your server to
pull for notifications should
you miss any or encounter any
errors processing them.
And there's an Order Processing
API, which allows
you to make requests to process
orders, such as
Charge, Ship, Cancel, Archive,
Refund, and so on.
Lastly, we have an API
for reporting.
The Order Report API allows
you to make requests and
download CSVs of orders.
So the three main APIs that
you need to know about and
that we're going to cover today
are the Cart API, the
Notification API, and the
Order Processing API.
And here we have some example
Cart API XML.
I stated previously, since
Checkout is an alternative
purchase flow, you're going
to need to convert your
representation of the buyer's
cart into the Cart API XML.
And we have client libraries to
help you in this process.
There's a couple components
of this cart.
The first is the items. And for
each item, the required
tags are item name, name of the
item, their description,
the price of the item and
currency, and the number of
items being sold, the
quantity of it.
Next there's shipping
and taxes.
With shipping, you have
several options.
With flat-rate shipping, you
basically define a flat rate
for a given geographic area.
For carrier-calculated, we'll
try to calculate the shipping
rate on your behalf by querying
the carriers,
provided that you provided the
origin, destination, weight,
and size of the package.
And lastly is
merchant-calculated shipping.
And as spoken before, we'll call
back to your server, and
your server will need to
determine the rate and then
respond to the request.
Next, there's tax tables.
And tax tables are
pretty simple.
It's just basically a fixed
percentage for a given
geographic area.
And you can have multiple tax
tables for different types of
items. Next, once you've created
the cart, you need to
post the cart to our server.
And there's two methods
of doing this.
There is the client-to-server
cart posts, which is basically
an HTML form post where you
generate the cart content on
the request. And then once the
customer is ready to check
out, they click the Google
Checkout button, which then
posts the cart to
Google Checkout.
The form post is composed
of two name-value pairs.
You have the cart, which
is a base64-encoded XML
representation of the cart API
XML, and the signature, which
is a base64 representation of
the cart HMAC-SHA-1 hash using
that merchant's merchant
key to sign the hash.
The server to server post
has a few more steps.
Here, the customer requests
your cart page.
And once they click the Google
Checkout button, it makes the
request to your server, which
then posts the Cart API XML to
Google Checkout.
Google Checkout processes this
and returns a redirect URL to
your server.
Your server then needs to pass
on the redirect URL back to
the client.
And your client code needs to
302 redirect the customer to
Google Checkout.
So once your customer has
completed the purchase, it's
time to fulfill the order.
The first piece of fulfilling
an order is to
find out about it.
And Checkout will automatically
send you an
email notifying you of the order
and will also have the
notification API.
So notifications are important
to sync between Checkout and
your server.
And today we'll be talking about
version 2.5 of the API.
And 2.5 is the latest version.
With it, a few things
have changed.
So instead of sending a full
notification to your server
directly, instead we'll send
your server a token.
And what your server needs
to do is then pull Google
Checkout using a Notification
of History API
provided in the token.
And we'll respond with
a full notification.
What this does is it removes
the requirement of a SSL
certificate for your server.
We've also simplified order
processing down to two
notifications and one order
processing request. The New
Order Notification tells you
that an order has been placed
and the order details.
The Authorization Amount
Notification tells you that
the order is now chargeable,
for how much, and when the
offer will expire.
Once you've received these two
notifications, you can fulfill
the order and then send the
charge and ship requests to
Google Checkout.
And what this does
is it charges the
request in Google Checkout.
And then it also marks it as
shipped for your customer.
If this were an older version
of the API, there would
probably a lot more arrows.
And then so many arrows
that it might not
even fit on this page.
But luckily, we've simplified
it in the past year.
And this is the New Order
Notification.
So New Order Notifications
contain a unique
Google order number.
The buyer's billing and
shipping addresses.
The buyer ID, which is
persistent between orders.
So your can use it to track your
buyers and the purchases
that they make.
The shopping cart, which
contains the items that a
customer has purchased.
The order adjustment, which
contains information about any
discounts, shipping, and taxes
that are applied to an order.
And finally the order total.
Next, we have the Authorization
Amount
Notification.
And what this contains is
information about the total
amount that's been authorized
for charge, and
when it will expire.
The order summary contains
a copy of the newer
notification.
And you can use it to quickly
pull order information without
making a query to
your database.
So the final step in fulfillment
is the Charge and
Ship Order Request. In this
request, you'll define the
total amount to charge up to
the chargeable amounts.
And if you're delivering
physical goods, the shipping
information.
We also have requests to
granularly process orders,
such as charge, ship,
refund, and archive.
All of the API documentation,
including requests,
notifications, and cart
API, can be found at
code.google.com/APIs/Checkout.
There you'll also find sample
code and client libraries.
So now that we have a basic
foundational knowledge of
Checkout from easy-to-use tools
to the APIs that power
them, let's see how they're
used in the real world.
Please welcome Rett Clevenger
and Marco Rodriguez from the
Steal Network.
RETT CLEVENGER: Thanks Peng.
The Steal Network is a
collection of deal of the day
sites targeted towards women.
We launched babysteals.com
three years ago and then
launched kidsteals and
scrapbooksteals a year later.
This last year we launched
kidcrawl.com, which is a
comparison shopping engine for
moms that crawls the web for
the lowest prices on baby, kid,
and maternity products.
Marco and I will be walking you
through our implementation
of Google Checkout on
babysteals.com.
So what is babysteals.com?
No, we do not steal babies.
Babysteals.com is a website that
features one new steal
every day at 9:00 AM and 9:00
PM Mountain Standard Time.
The community doesn't know what
the item will be or how
many will be available, but they
do know that it'll be a
boutique-quality item that
is relevant to them
and up to 80% off.
We offer appointment-based
viewing and utilize product
expertise, scarcity, and a
community of like-minded moms
to entertain women
around the world.
We all know women
love to shop.
They have a social need to
try something new and
to get a good deal.
We combined them.
For all you ladies in the
audience who have kids, be
careful with the site.
It's awfully addicting.
As Peng and Mihai mentioned,
Google Checkout has a lot of
functionality.
But you do need to build some
sort of interface to organize
all the information required
to make a purchase.
This is a look at what we've
built at our internal admin.
As you can tell, there's
different tabs for the
different critical
elements that are
required to make a purchase.
This is where we store the
information related to the
product weight, the images, the
description, and a lot of
other features.
We can't go through it in
complete detail, but I chose
to focus on the Shipping tab
here because, as many of you
know, shipping can make or break
any e-commerce business.
Shipping is especially important
for us because all
of the items that we feature
each day are very unique in
size and shape and
availability.
So we built this interface to be
able to modify the shipping
for each feature that
we present.
We use carrier-calculated most
often, but we also have the
ability to offer flat-rate and
free shipping, as well as add
additional carriers like FedEx
and MediaMail for books and
videos depending
on the product.
We also designate the country
of origin and the customs
description to help expedite
shipping orders to Canada.
In the future, we plan to expand
our shipping options by
being able to easily edit
the Ship From address to
accommodate external drop
ship locations.
Marco will now walk you through
this same thing from a
coding perspective.
MARCO RODRIGUEZ: As you can you
imagine, programming all
this chip combination
is not simple.
However, with Google
Checkout, we have
simplified the problem.
They provide a Checkout HTML API
where we can include the
shipping methods according
to our needs.
For every customer, we can
indicate the available
shipping options for that
specific order.
To use the custom API
instructions, what you need to
do is you need to place them
inside a form tag with the ID
googlecart-checkout.config.
This form will be submitted
along with the
contents of the cart.
The most common scenario for us
is that we send the order
information to Google along with
the request to calculate
the shipping based on weight.
Like this example.
USPS Priority Mail, Parcel Post,
FedEx Home Delivery are
some of the shipping methods
available just
to mention a few.
There are more than that.
If you need something different
like a special
shipping method not offered by
Google, that's not a problem.
It is possible to calculate the
shipping fee and include
it as a shipping option
before sending the
information to Google.
We offer USPS First Class and
First Class Mail International
package to our customers for
orders below 13 ounces.
If you need to also offer free
shipping for some of your
products, that's
not a problem.
It is possible to do it.
Just include a custom shipping
method with a CRS value.
And if you need to offer also
local pick-up, you can do it.
That's easy.
Google offers the possibility
to include shipping
restrictions.
So you can instruct
Google where
this option is available.
We offer only local pick-up
for Utah residents.
RETT CLEVENGER: OK.
So let's look through the
process from the customer's
shopping experience.
So the first thing
to note, we're
designed for speed shopping.
It only takes three clicks to
buy an item start to finish
using Google Checkout.
We start out with a cart that is
out of sight, out of mind.
As you'll notice in the top
right corner, we've used CSS
to modify the color band of the
cart to match the design
of our website.
As you add items to the cart,
it expands over non-critical
elements of the page.
As soon as the consumer clicks
Google Checkout, we validate
the inventory and the max order
limit that we set to
prevent resellers.
If the item has already sold
out by the time they click
Check Out, we display a pop-up
window that tells them that
we've adjusted their cart
accordingly and allow them to
continue on.
At this point, as soon as they
enter into Google Checkout,
they have four minutes to
complete their purchase.
We set that four-minute
limitation due to the nature
of our business.
Google Checkout does an
excellent job of keeping it
extremely simple and making it
very quick to place an order.
They specify the default
payment and the default
shipping address based
on your user setting.
Do note, though, that having a
default shipping address can
be problematic for fulfillment
because a lot of people forget
to change their address
after they've moved.
They've actually made it so
quick and easy to place the
order that it's easy to gloss
over an address that you
recognize, but not necessarily
realize that
it's your old address.
And we have run into that
problem a few times.
But the benefits far outweigh
the cost of that.
I can't reiterate enough how
important it is and how
valuable it is to have Google
process and store all of the
payment information.
It relieves merchants like us
from a huge burden from PCI
compliance and other
security risks.
It really allows us to focus on
our core business, not on
processing payments.
Once the order is submitted,
Google Checkout sends an email
to the consumer with
the confirmation.
And it also has a 15-minute
buyer's remorse window where
the customer can cancel their
order without contacting our
customer service team, which
is a very nice feature.
We currently get about 10% of
our traffic through the mobile
version of our website.
Here's a look at what Google
has offered for
their mobile cart.
It's even more clean
and more simple
than the browser version.
But it does have a couple of
shipping method bugs that
they're currently working on.
And it doesn't give you
the option to enter
in a promotion code.
Which isn't a real big deal for
our business model, but it
does cause frustration and
confusion with consumers when
we do offer a promotion code,
and they can't enter it in
through the mobile device.
I have complete faith that all
those things will be fixed
quickly, but do be aware
of those things.
All right.
So now that we've covered the
ordering process, let's take a
look at another critical
component to online business,
which is inventory control.
Inventory control is very
important because the user
doesn't have the ability to walk
around the store with the
product in-hand.
We feel very strongly that if a
consumer places an order and
gives us payment, we
need to ship that
order as soon as possible.
We ship orders same day
95% of the time.
Come to find out, pregnant
women really like fast
deliveries.
Without proper inventory
control, shipping same day
becomes nearly impossible.
Like I said earlier, we're
all about speed shopping.
So we've had to create this
buffer system to help create a
buffer that can allow us to
monitor the speed of sales and
adjust the sold-out status on
our page without adjusting the
actual inventory.
When a customer clicks Place
Order Now in Google Checkout,
it doesn't have the ability
to validate the
inventory at that time.
Like I said earlier, we have
that four-minute cart timeout.
So within those four minutes,
you do have the ability to
have some orders come through
that had valid inventory when
they placed it.
But there's several other people
in cart during that
four minutes.
And it can create
some oversells.
So we created this buffer to
help mitigate that and also to
help adjust for cancellations
that are caused during that
15-minute buyer's
remorse window.
When items are cancelled, we
don't necessarily want our
site to go back up available
for sale.
So we use this to be able to
see what's going on and be
able to control all the
aspects of that.
Setting the buffer is
certainly not easy.
It depends on a lot of
uncontrollable variables: the
site traffic, the number of
variants that we have for
sale, the price of the item,
a lot of different things.
So what we've done is made it
so that we can at least
monitor and watch efficiently
and be able to react
accordingly.
If an order contains
a sold-out item, we
still accept the order.
But we create a status called
a pending oversale and ship
the rest of the remaining items,
validate our inventory,
and then take a look at them and
try to fulfill them if we
can or cancel them
if we can't.
Marco will now walk you through
this same process from
a coding perspective.
MARCO RODRIGUEZ: To prevent
oversells, we utilize the
Shopping Cart JavaScript API
to validate inventory just
before sending the order
to Google Checkout.
A JavaScript hook has been set
up by implementing the Google
Cart and Checkout
click function.
So when the user clicks on the
Google Checkout button, it
actually, before going to
Google, makes and Ajax call to
our server to do a final review
of the cart contents.
This will decrease the number
of oversales by like 80%.
RETT CLEVENGER: So now
let's talk about
how we manage orders.
As Peng mentioned, Google
Checkout has an interface that
allows you to place orders in
four different statuses.
You have Pending.
You have Charged.
You have Shipped.
And you have Archived.
For babysteals, we need more
statuses than that, so we
added quite a few.
You'll notice here we added
Ready To Print and Printed
between the Charged and
Shipped status.
We also have different statuses
for orders that we're
waiting for a response
from a customer.
And we use these statuses
to manage our
local pick-up queues.
We use the filter on the left
here to select like orders to
help expedite the fulfillment
and the shipping of orders.
We've found that it makes it a
lot easier and a lot quicker
to ship orders--
since we are a deal of
the day website--
that have similar items rather
than shipping orders in the
sequence that they come in.
It allows us to batch process
a lot of our fulfillment.
We also use these queues
to batch shipped order
notification and archive
notifications to Google Checkout.
Google Checkout provides a
really nice peer-to-peer
resource as well for those
that use Google Checkout.
As you can see from this demo,
the simplicity of our site
matches well with the simplicity
of Google Checkout.
And the majority of our
customers are satisfied.
We've got a 4.8 out of
5 star rate review.
We've had over 23,000 user
reviews on babysteals.com
alone, 89% of which have
been a 5-star review.
Moms love babysteals and they
love Google Checkout.
So let's wrap it up with the
lessons learned over the last
three years of using Google
Checkout exclusively.
First off, it's easy
to implement.
Like Mihai said, it can be set
up in less than one day.
Google Checkout is simple,
affordable, and reliable.
We've processed over $13 million
in revenue within our
three sites and have processed
over 500,000 orders from
babysteals alone in the
last three years.
We've had less than 10
performance issues over that
period of time, all of which
have been resolved and fixed
the same day.
Google is a trusted brand.
We've had very few customers
mention to us that they didn't
want to create a Google
account in order
to order from us.
And, most importantly, Google
allows us to keep it simple.
Our business model is based
on marketing and building
community, not on technology.
Google allows us to
stay focused.
Thank you.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Hi.
My name is Satyajeet Salgar and
I'm a product manager on
the Google Checkout Team.
Now Peng and Mihai gave you a
sense of what the product is
and some of the tools
we have available.
And Rett and Marco talked about
what it's like to run a
successful e-commerce business
on top of Google Checkout.
I'd like to step back a little
bit, talk a little bit about
some of the challenges that we
see in the payments business,
what our plan for success is,
and why we really want succeed
to make this a better
product for you.
Finally, I want to announce
a few new things.
And then we want to open
it up for Q&A.
Payments, like many other
businesses, requires you to
crack a chicken and
egg problem.
Now what do I mean by that?
Buyers continually tell us that
they love the simplicity
of Checkout.
They love the security, they
love the user experience.
Sellers tell us that they
like the fraud controls.
They love to implement it, but
they have a limited amount of
time and want to invest in the
payment solution that will
give them the most buyers.
Buyers, on the other hand, tell
us again and again they
wish Google Checkout was
available everywhere they
wanted to transact.
So more buyers makes it more
useful to sellers.
Having more sellers is actually
what most buyers want.
So what do you do?
The answer, of course, is you
do a little bit of both.
Peng described to you our
triple rainbow growth.
We're proud of that, but
this is important
for a couple of reasons.
Now traditionally, we've relied
on you, our developers,
our sellers, our merchants to
grow our buyer network.
People like Rett and Marco,
sites across the web, hundreds
of thousands of merchants.
But now as Commerce and Google
grows, this is something that
Google can help with directly.
Over the last year, a huge
part of our growth of
Checkout, as well as our buyer
base, has been through
Commerce and Google.
Through Android Market, through
Google Voice, the
Chrome Web Store, YouTube,
which relaunched
their rental site.
Google eBooks.
And many, many more.
And this is important because
when someone transacts on
Google Commerce, they
have created a
Google Checkout account.
So when they come to your site,
they're already signed
up and a couple of
clicks away from
completing their purchase.
We believe this makes Google
Checkout a more valuable
product to developers.
But that's not enough.
We think about how
we want to serve
developers in three ways.
The first, we want to make
the tools we have
much easier to use.
We want to offer you new and
more powerful tools.
And finally, we want
to grow and support
our developer community.
On the first bucket, making it
easier to use the tools we
have, we're proud of the work
we've done the last year and
actually delighted to see the
impact that it's had on you,
the developer community.
Launching APID 2.5, actually
we've seen how it's made
integration with Checkout
much easier.
Similarly, we're glad to see the
growth in the use of Buy
Now merchants and
Shopping Carts.
I'll talk a little bit more
about the new tools we're
going to make available to
you, and you can find out
about a lot of them here
at Google I/O.
Finally, we're committed,
through our developer forums
and through the Developer
Relations team led by Peng and
Mihai, to your success and to
helping you succeed with
Google Checkout.
So what's new?
Developers often tell us they
wish that they could have a
button where they could have
their users actually support
their projects, their blog, or
something they were were
working on.
Now, for a number of reasons,
our Donate button is
restricted to non-profits.
However, in the next couple of
weeks, on Google Blogger,
we'll be making available the
Support button, which you can
actually use to have your users
support your blog or
your sites.
If you can stay in this room,
you'll learn more
about Google One Pass.
This a product, which you can
use to control access to your
digital content.
The team had a lot of success
with the news vertical, and
they're excited to talk to
you about their product.
Tomorrow you can learn about
In-App Payments for the web,
which is a simplified buy flow
for HTML and Flash developers.
So what is your takeaway
from here?
First, I don't want to
talk about payments.
I want you to remember
that monetization
is more than payments.
Google offers tons of tools
for you to help
monetize your sites.
People tell me we have
a relatively
successful ads business.
So think about ad sense and
display ads on your site.
Think about using ad words to
get more users to your site.
Think about using Google
Analytics to understand what
users are actually doing on
your site and uncover new
sources of revenue.
Think about Shopping APIs to
improve discoverability.
There are tons of tools
that Google
offers to help you monetize.
But finally do think about
Commerce and Payments.
There has never been a better
time to think about
e-commerce.
Last year, the industry in the
United States was estimated at
about $175 billion.
It's estimated to grow to $300
billion in a few years.
And globally, in a couple
of years, it will
cross over $1 trillion.
There is tons of opportunity
there.
However, the challenges
remain the same.
Fraud continues to be a huge
challenge on online commerce.
We're convinced we have
the best fraud
system available online.
Compliance is a huge challenge,
especially
internationally, and especially
if you aren't compliant.
But again, this is something
that Google Checkout
can help you with.
Conversions.
Making sure that once the user
intends to buy, nothing gets
in their way from completing
their purchase.
Again, this is something
that Google Checkout
can help you with.
So we have a flexible
API and tools to
help you build a business.
What does that mean?
Get started.
Create a Google Checkout
account.
Download some sample code.
Check out our Docs
and our website.
Engage with us on Twitter,
online, and, of
course, right now.
So let's start the questions.
And, by the way,
one more thing.
If you hang around a little bit,
on your way out, Jessica
Smallen will have some swag for
you to carry home as well.
And why doesn't everyone
come up for questions?
Yeah.
Sure.
If you can come up here, or we
can repeat your question.
Why don't we start there.
AUDIENCE: I'm from
Montreal, and we
have a weird tax system.
They have a tax.
And they've got the
[INAUDIBLE].
And then the province charges
tax on everything.
Is there a way to make that
simple [INAUDIBLE]?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: So right now,
actually Google Checkout
isn't available in Canada.
AUDIENCE: What?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Yes.
Except for digital goods
and Android market.
And one of the many reasons
was the back system.
So again, that's something
we're working on.
And we do want to expand
internationally.
Why don't we start at the back
and then move forward?
The gentleman there.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
I'm kind of new to the
commercing, but I understand
that selling online goods will
be directionally shifted.
One of the things that I would
like to be able to do is
recurring payments.
Is that something that Google
Checkout is for?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Yes, we have
a Recurring Payments API that
allows you to do recurring
payments.
We've had it in beta
now for over a
year and a half, actually.
PENG YING: A long time.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: We should
take it out of beta.
But yeah, we support
recurring payments.
AUDIENCE: So how do
you get the money?
So people run through
the flow, and then
they make the purchase.
Is it attached to
some accounts?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Rett, how
do you get the money?
RETT CLEVENGER: How do
you get the money?
Well, you set up
direct deposit.
So at all times in Google
Checkout, in the interface,
you can look at the Payments
tab and see what you
transacted for the day.
And then a few days later, that
same amount will end up
in your checking account after
they've done all the fraud
verification and processed
all the credit cards and
that sort of thing.
So there is a little bit of a
lag, of a delay, but once you
get moving, it all just moves
with the speed of business.
The gentleman back there.
AUDIENCE: How much
does it cost?
And can a customer with a
credit card use Google
Checkout without creating
a Google account?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Do you
want to take that?
PENG YING: Can we have a mic
or something down here?
Well, it's a tiered
fee structure.
And it's very similar
to PayPal.
Actually, I think it's kind
of identical to PayPal's.
The lowest is 2.9%.
And what is it?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: The highest
goes up to 1.9 depending upon
your transaction volume
per month.
You get put in a tier.
And it goes from 1.9 to 2.9%.
PENG YING: He's right.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: And the second
question was about
creating a Google account?
AUDIENCE: Right.
You have a customer with a
credit card [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
SATYAJEET SALGAR: So, no.
So right now you do need to
create a Google account in
order to complete
a transaction.
The gentleman right
next to you.
AUDIENCE: Do you support
micropayments?
Like $1 or less?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: We do
support a dollar.
So we do support it.
And you'll actually find lots
of goods in Android Market
that are priced at $0.99.
MIHAI IONESCUE: All of my
testing orders are for $0.01.
PENG YING: For micropayments,
you should probably attend
tomorrow's talk about
In-App Payments.
I think that's probably a better
venue of purchasing.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: The
gentleman in front.
Oh, he's had his hand
up for a while.
AUDIENCE: Do you guys support
Level 3 [INAUDIBLE]
pass through?
So that item level transactions
to the credit
cards and the categorization
of [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
the government?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: I'm not sure
I understand the question.
But we should chat
after this later.
So you mean, will we basically,
based on the credit
card transaction, back out
the elements, the items?
AUDIENCE: Are you a Level 1
provider, or do you go down to
Level 2 or 3?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: No, we
are a Level 1 provider.
AUDIENCE: Level 1?
And then how do you guys handle
the chargeback process?
I looked online, and there
was just like emails.
As a merchant, how
does that happen?
And how does that work
with your back end
system that you have?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: So to repeat
the question, how do we handle
the chargeback process?
RETT CLEVENGER: Yeah,
it does happen.
But if you do good business, it
doesn't happen very often.
So it becomes one of those
things where it's somewhat of
a subjective thing.
You try to do as good a job
that you can with your
tracking and all the other
elements that can prove that
you've done what
you need to do.
But at the end of the day,
it does come up.
It doesn't happen very often.
A lot of people, at least in our
business, they really did
want the item.
And as long as you did
everything you could in a
correct way, then they're
satisfied.
But yeah, it does come up.
PENG YING: Gentleman
behind him.
AUDIENCE: I'm one of
those bloggers who
wanted a Donate button.
And I'm confused about the
difference between a Donate
button and a Support button.
Can I call it a Donate button?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: No,
so you should call
it a Support button.
And the reason is because of the
way we're set up, Donate
has a certain connotation
and is applied only to
non-profits.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Yep.
I had the same reaction and
expression on my face.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain why?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Legally, it
has certain implications
because of money transferring
licenses and the
way we're set up.
So Donate, as we're set up,
applies to nonprofits
[INAUDIBLE]
legal.
Remember I talked about
compliance?
This is part of it.
Gentleman behind you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SATYAJEET SALGAR: All right.
So we'll get better at repeating
the question or
coming to the mic.
Gentleman at the mic?
AUDIENCE: What does it mean if
it's using Google Checkout
compared to PayPal?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: So I think
there are similarities within
the product, but Google Checkout
is really meant to
simplify the shopping
experience.
PayPal provides a couple of
products that end up doing
something similar.
We believe that we have the best
in class fraud system and
provide a better user
experience.
And we have a lot of merchants
that support what we say.
So you're right.
There are pieces of
functionality
that are very similar.
And I think experiences as a
merchant, experiences as a
buyer will speak to the
differences between the products.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I work at NPR.
And we have a lot of donations
that we would like to process,
but there's a lot of different
entities within our system
that the money would
need to go to.
Is it possible for us to have
one entry point that would
actually go out to many
different sources in the end
without us ever actually
touching the money?
PENG YING: Disbursements.
To the best of my knowledge, we
don't have the Disbursement
API that allows you to
distribute the income.
Do you know anything
like that?
SATYAJEET SALGAR:
No, there is--
I'd love to talk to you about
your use case, but in essence
there's one bank account that
we push the money to.
AUDIENCE: He's talking about
split payments, what PayPal
calls split payments.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: I got it.
No, we don't support
split payments.
AUDIENCE: So UPS delivers
Saturday service
to certain zip codes.
And if a user wants to ship
to certain zip codes on a
Saturday, is there a call to go
to a no, you can't deliver
there on Saturday type deal?
I thought there was an API
that goes there, and it
calculates the shipping.
PENG YING: I think what you're
talking about is a
carrier-calculated
shipping API.
Right now, Saturday delivery
service is a different option
than like UPS Ground.
Would it be UPS Ground with
Saturday service?
Or is it just UPS Ground?
RETT CLEVENGER: It's
a separate service.
PENG YING: It's a separate
service?
Then I don't think, at this
point, we might not support
that service.
But we're always looking to
improve our functionality.
AUDIENCE: This is a question
for the Steal Network guys.
You mentioned you had a buffer
between, I'm assuming, your
back end business system that's
managing your inventory
and the Google Checkout
process.
Can you speak to your process
there a little bit in terms of
how many items you're dealing
with, and how you actually get
those things up into
Checkout and
manage that buffer process?
RETT CLEVENGER: Sure.
It changes every day.
We've toyed with a couple
different algorithms to try to
do predictive analysis for how
many the right number is based
on all the different
variables.
But when it came down to it,
the human interaction with
being able to visually predict
before this deal goes live--
so five minutes before this deal
goes live, we go in and
set the buffer.
And no matter what we
set, we're wrong.
And so what we created is a
dashboard to at least be able
to see what's going on.
Because one of the things that's
unique about us is that
we have one product, but we
could have several sizes or
several colors available
at the same time.
All of those different
variants sell
at different speeds.
And so one buffer for all
doesn't work, but what we did
is surface the information so
that we can visually see.
And we know within minutes.
We've actually had products sell
at 180 orders per minute.
So you can watch very
quickly what's taken
off and what's not.
And then you just sit
and adjust the
buffer in real time.
So you can increase it if you
low-balled it, or you can
start to decrease it if the
speed in which the sales are
happening are slower than
what you predicted.
So on that slide that I had,
you saw two graphs.
And one of them is to show the
orders per minute to help you
gauge OK, if I'm at 50 orders
per minute and my buffer's
only 20, I don't have
a chance, right?
I need to equal those out.
But if my orders per minute are
10 orders per minute, and
I have a buffer of 20, then the
probability of that many
people being in Checkout
for that four-minute
timeframe is less.
But at the end of the day,
you don't know until
it's finally over.
And I have to say, it's one of
the only things that made us
work a little bit harder
than what we expected.
And it's all because of that
inability to validate the
inventory when they hit
Place Order Now.
You can validate the inventory
before they go into it, but
there is a timeframe.
And then the other thing to be
aware of is that 15-minute
buyer's remorse window.
That introduces cancellations
back into your system that you
have to figure out something
to deal with.
And for us, we make judgment
calls for whether we're going
to make the product available
for sale or not.
Sometimes those cancellations
offset the oversells, and
everything washes out.
And everybody's happy.
MARCO RODRIGUEZ: Something I
want to add for you is that it
is important for us because
we don't take back orders.
If you are able to take back
orders, it doesn't matter if
you have oversales.
RETT CLEVENGER: Right.
We have what we have,
and it's gone.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
On certain carriers on the
Android Market, you can choose
to pay with your billing.
Does Google plan to do that with
Checkout, maybe like Big
Coins or PayPal or anything?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: So right now,
that feature is available
only in Android Market.
And the idea is-- it's
through Checkout--
but the idea is we support
carrier billing for Android
Market only.
AUDIENCE: What about like
carrier billing for Checkout?
You think that's
ever possible?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: So at least
the way we think about it is
we have carrier billing for
Checkout, but for now there
are no plans to take it
beyond Android Market.
Sure.
Do you mind coming
up to the mic?
Or I can repeat your question,
that's fine.
AUDIENCE: So Apple and PayPal
released a kind of accounts in
force number.
Do you guys ever talk about
that, about how many accounts
are [INAUDIBLE]?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Sure, so the
question was Apple and PayPal
had released a number.
Do we talk about it?
We don't.
The only number I think we have
right now are hundreds of
thousands of merchants and
millions of buyers.
AUDIENCE: Can you mention
what merchant
countries you support?
RETT CLEVENGER: Yeah,
so US and Canada.
You'd be amazed at how many
orders we ship to Canada.
It is one of those things, like
Marco had mentioned, the
way that they've built Google
Checkout is that you can
manipulate the shipping
options, do a lot
of different things.
And so we've been able to offer
carrier-calculated or
flat-rate to Canadians.
And we've found that they really
do appreciate it when
US companies will go
to the extra effort
of shipping to Canada.
It is more work on our end.
You've got to fill out customs
forms and different things.
But at the end of the day, they
have limited options,
especially for boutique-quality
items like we sell.
We'll have 20 to 30%
of our orders in a
day going up to Canada.
They have to wait quite a bit
longer for the delivery, but
they're used to it.
There's an exchange at the
border and their Canadian post
isn't extremely fast. But at the
end of the day, they are
appreciative that we will sell
to them up there because a lot
of the brands that we sell
themselves will not ship
directly to Canada.
So they can get the products
through us.
PENG YING: I think you're
talking about for developers,
which countries can actually
sell through Checkout, right?
AUDIENCE: Very sorry.
Yes.
RETT CLEVENGER: Oh, I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: It was a
very kind reply.
I just didn't articulate the
question well enough.
Thank you.
The question I meant to ask
was what merchant bank
accounts you guys support.
PENG YING: So for Checkout
right now, for web-based
Checkout, it's just in
the US and UK still.
But for things like Android
Market, we support a number of
additional countries.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
a road map for
other merchant countries?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: We don't
have a timeline,
a road map as yet.
But again, we do want to grow
Checkout internationally.
Through starting with Android
Market, we've removed a lot of
the roadblocks to do that.
We don't have a timeline
yet to talk about.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I would like to know if Google
gets a cut of every sale, a
commission?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: We do have
a transaction fee, so
that's the cut for--
AUDIENCE: What is the amount?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: It ranges
depending upon
volume on your site.
It ranges from 1.9% to 2.9%.
AUDIENCE: Oh, was that
the question before?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, OK, I
think I've got it.
Thank you.
RETT CLEVENGER: But I can tell
you, no matter what you do, if
you're processing credit cards,
you're going to have a
credit card transaction fee.
The fact that you can use
Google Checkout in the
interface for free,
essentially--
it really is free.
No matter what you do, you're
going to pay a fee to process
credit cards unless you're
the bank yourself.
It is very competitively priced
and one of the main
reasons why we selected
Google Checkout.
PENG YING: Let's go
to the back first.
AUDIENCE: One of the questions
earlier asked, whether you
need to create a Google
account, and
the answer was yes.
But I'm wondering if you could
say more about why that is.
It seems like a big barrier
to conversion.
It's definitely not the
three-click process you're
hoping for.
I've got my credit
card in hand--
oh, I guess I'd have to--
Nah, maybe not.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: There's
a trade-off.
That's the first purchase.
But think about the
second, right?
Which is you're signed up.
You're literally a couple
of clicks away.
And you don't have to enter
your credit card again.
AUDIENCE: On our site, we allow
you to create a login
after you give us
a credit card.
And that's one of the things
you should do.
That way I've got your money.
And if you want to purchase
with us again, you'll
be able to do so.
Let me rephrase my question.
Does Google want to remove that
restriction, or is this
restriction something
that Google
believes is a good thing?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: We believe it
helps the user experience.
I lifted it off our feedback,
we think this is the right
combination for the
user in this case.
AUDIENCE: I disagree.
Thank you.
RETT CLEVENGER: From the
merchant's perspective, we did
battle this, especially three
years ago when Google Checkout
wasn't very well known.
We did get a lot of feedback,
I do not want to have to
create a Google account in
order to order from you.
In hindsight, now they
thank us because it
is that much faster.
And the platform itself
has grown wider.
And now they're seeing more
usefulness of that account.
So you're right, there was
a significant resistance.
And we second-guessed
it a little bit.
We let it go long enough.
And our site is addicting enough
that once they do get
that second and third, they do
appreciate the functionality
after the fact.
MARCO RODRIGUEZ: I can tell you
from experience that one
year ago, we offered
both credit card
payment and Google Checkout.
And the maximum day was like
3% transactions over the
credit card.
People still preferred
Google Checkout.
And we had a couple days where
Google Checkout had troubles.
And people were waiting for
Google Checkout, even when the
credit card was enabled.
PENG YING: Last question.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: Last question
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I saw
that you can specify the
currency in the APIs.
And you said that Google
Checkout is only available in
the US right now?
I'm kind of confused.
If I have an international
site and I'm offering in
Euros, can I use Google
Checkout to
specify that currency?
And do you convert the amount?
SATYAJEET SALGAR: I'm not sure
which slide it was, but--
So we actually don't offer
things beyond the United
States and the UK.
I'm not sure what's--
and I guess your currency
was the US and the UK.
AUDIENCE: I see.
So it's only limited to those
two currencies right now.
OK.
Got it.
Thanks.
PENG YING: Unless you're doing
the Android Market or
something else, then we also
support additional currencies.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: I believe
we're done.
PENG YING: Yeah, sorry.
SATYAJEET SALGAR: But you should
ask your question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SATYAJEET SALGAR: And to be
clear, buyers can pay in any
currency as long as their
credit card supports it.
It's the currency
that you charge.
So you can be in another country
and pay for something
in dollars.
It's more the currency that
we'll actually charge your
credit card in.
PENG YING: Thank you guys.